aux murs sirène président de rédaction
france et spécialiste de la turquie à
madame sirène bienvenus bonjour merci
merci à vous de m'avoir est accueilli
sur votre plateau pour intervenir sur le
sujet qui nous tient particulièrement à
coeur
justement vient de l'entente dans cette
réaction du président du parlement turc
heures bustaffa center qui parla
d'islamophobie primitive de la part du
chef de l'état emmanuel macron de
réaction malheureusement je tiens à dire
que nous les franco turque nous sommes
particulièrement triste et inquiet et
des récentes déclarations du président
marc ronde qui alimente la
stigmatisation dans la turquie mais
franco turque et les musulmans dans un
sens plus général et donc c'est ce sont
des dix couches d des actes
malheureusement qu'on peut qualifier
aussi d'islamophobe et de turcophobes et
qu'il faut lutter et aussi nous avons
peur de les percussions de ce genre de
discours malheureusement hier soir nous
avons vécu un double attentat en
allemagne avec plusieurs morts dont des
turcs
juste après justement cette annonce de
la lutte contre le communautarisme le
séparatisme de du président manque long
et nous sommes vraiment maintenant nous
avons peur des répercussions aussi en
france sur la sécurité des milliers de
ses cent mille francs clôture mais aussi
des millions de musulmans qui vivaient
sur le sol français
alors emmanuel macron estimé donc on ne
pouvait pas voir sur le sol français
les lois de la turquie il parlait d
alcoa qui serait selon le président en
fait des cours plus politisés que des
cours linguistiques et nous pensons que
les enfants d'origine turque ils ont le
droit d'apprendre leur langue et leur
culture d'origine ils ont ce droit est
malheureusement ce droit a été enlevée
par le président marc rhône en
prétextant une influence étrangère donc
le les ingérences turc
ce qui est totalement faux et je tiens à
préciser ici que nous avons en turquie
qui est qualifié constamment dans les
médias français comme une dictature
neuf établissements scolaires français
est donc deux écoles directement
rattaché à au ministère de l'éducation
française le lycée pierre loti à
istanbul le lycée charles de gaulle à
ankara et c'est la france l'allemagne
qui envoient des fonctionnaires en
turquie époux qu'ils enferment dans ces
écoles
et par exemple avec la nouvelle réforme
des halles qu ils exigeaient que les
fonctionnaires envoyés par la turquie
maîtrise le français alors que et les
fonctionnaires français qui sont
envoyées en turquie ne maîtrisent pas la
lecture donc du coup c'est on voit que
c'était vraiment d'un prétexte
et nous sommes vraiment conséquente à
des interdictions les écoles c'est
toujours une richesse moi même je suis
diplômé d'une école française fondée en
1783 en turquie à istanbul à l'époque
ottomane donc à manger en majorité
musulman savoure ce soit qui en fait
notre pays est vraiment privilégié
l'ouverture d'esprit la tolérance et
l'éducation pour tous est aujourd'hui si
je peux parler en français justement
c'est grâce à cette école et on doit est
aussi autorisé la création des écoles
turques et la poursuite de
l'enseignement de tubes dans les écoles
françaises
alors justement concernant ses locaux
ans c'est un partenariat entre la france
et certains autres pays étrangers
l'algérie le maroc la turquie le
portugal la roumanie
seppi justement ne se sont pas encore
exprimés ils vont en tout cas n'ont rien
dit concernant la fermeture de ses
locaux qui vont être remplacés par des
aides est un système qui avait été déjà
mis en place
pourquoi il n'ya que recep tayyip
erdogan qui a réagi pour le moment parce
que malheureusement dans ses discours le
président emmanuel marc clown il a
réellement ciblé visé la communauté
franco tuque les turcs et la turquie il
a parlé des ingérences turquie la
parlait de d'études qui vivent sur le
sol français c'est pour ça que notre
président nil a réagi à ces propos et
est malheureusement actuellement on est
visée alors qui en fait c'est une
communauté qui est complètement intégré
bien intégrés dans les deux pays à la
fois en turquie en france qui est connu
comme des personnes travailleuses qui ne
pose aucun souci de délinquance de
violence de radicalisme donc on ne
comprend pas du tout de quoi il parle
quand népal du séparatisme du
communautarisme n'est pas séparatistes
on n'est pas communautariste
au contraire on est un pont entre les
deux pays et nous combattons justement
les l'emploi de cette arme qui font plus
penser à une politique de dictature de
type hitler qu'une démocratie et on
n'est pas là pour diviser la société on
est au contraire la haye pour
renforcer les liens entre la turquie et
la france à mon avis le président
français il devrait pleuvoir ces
stratégies allant vers la turquie et le
franco turc et ils doivent renforcer ses
liens avec à la fois notre pays et notre
communauté ici très rapidement de estimé
donc emmanuel mâcon vise la communauté
franco-turcs rien la communauté turque
de france
pourquoi selon vous ok donc et est
sincèrement il ya trois raisons la
première raison ce sont les crises
politiques et diplomatiques que vivent
actuellement la turquie à la france vous
savez que les deux pays ont des dossiers
complètement divergents à la fois en
syrie en libye en méditerranée orientale
et en afrique donc en syrie il y eut le
trait des troupes américains sans l'aval
des français et après l'opération
militaire de la turquie qui n'a pas été
approuvé par le par la france et ensuite
en libye et la turquie et soutient le
gouvernement d'union nationale le génie
de sa rage alors que la france soutient
le maréchal haftar et il ya déjà une
divergence d'intérêts dans ce pays aussi
en méditerranée orientale
la turquie fait de recherche de
ressources naturelles et contrairement à
la volonté de la france de la grèce de
l'administration chypriote grecque
donc ça aussi c'est sont confiantes les
deux pays et enfin en afrique on voit
que et la turquie dans force de plus en
plus on sauve trois balles et avec une
présence accrue dans les pays sur le
continent africain ce qui ne plaît pas
forcément et à paris et ensuite la
deuxième raison qu'on peut citer c'est
une raisons électoralistes
parce que le moment où le président marc
rhône a annoncé sa lutte contre le
communautarisme et le séparatisme
c'était lors du dîner annuel du ccas qui
veut dire le conseil de coordination des
organisations arméniennes de france donc
c'est complètement paradoxale d'annoncer
une lutte contre le communautarisme dans
un dîner qui est complètement
communautarisme c'est incompréhensible
et donc on est à l'approché des
élections municipales ça se voit
clairement qu'il essaie de gagner des
votes à la fois du lobby arménien mais
aussi
de la droite de l'extrême droite qui est
anti islam en turquie et la troisième
raison que je peux évoquer et c'est une
raison ne pas vraiment une stratégie de
communication de marketing c'est pour
détourner l'attention du peuple français
dès problèmes essentiels en france comme
quand vous voyez avec les manifestations
des gilets jaunes les manifestations
contre la réforme des retraites
il ya d'autres soucis un terme qu'il
faut les autres plutôt que de parler de
la turquie des francos tube de l'islam à
chaque fois qu'on se sent coincé on veut
gagner des votes aux murs sirène merci
d'avoir été avec moi je rappelle que
vous êtes président de rédaction france
et spécialiste de la turquie merci pour
votre analyse
ah merci à vous